cette maison a vu grandir rené lévesque
jusqu'a ces 14 ans elle est désormais la
propriété de québec une nouvelle qui
réjouit louis bernard avec la fondation
de la maison rené-lévesque
il a consacré plusieurs années à tenter
d'acquérir cette résidence afin d'en
faire un lieu rendant hommage aux
politiciens faute d'avoir pu s'entendre
avec le propriétaire l'organisation
c'est plutôt lancer dans le projet de
création de l'espace rené lévesque
inauguré à new carlisle en 2010 9
juillet pas tout autant mais est ce que
ça vaut permet ça va permette de
visiteurs d'ici ou en jaune visiteurs
qui viennent à new carlisle de voir la
maison
si c'est pour ma visite et c'est une
autre paire de manches parce que si on
me faire rouler du public ne faut rien
dit ni me gêne le ministère de la
culture a l'intention de procéder à un
bilan de l'état des lieux qui nécessite
une importante cure de jouvence puis de
procéder aux travaux nécessaires à la
conservation et à la mise en valeur de
la maison c'est ensuite que seront
analysés les vocations potentiel la
nouvelle de la sauvegarde du bâtiment
qui a demandé beaucoup de temps suscite
de la satisfaction mais aussi des
attentes rené lévesque a marqué le toit
québec et beaucoup de gens te demande je
demandais pourquoi la raison était un si
piètre état c'est ce que l'on attend
d'une restauration on entre dans une
dans une phase td tout
le monsieur par ailleurs le gouvernement
actuel je me réjouis qu'il achetait
maintenant j'espère que la mise en
valeur de la maison voit ce faire de
façon concertée avec le milieu et non de
la façon qu'on a mis en place par
exemple les espaces bleus le 16 rue mon
sort elle a été reconnue monument
historique en 1995 par le gouvernement
péquiste de jacques parizeau et si
roxane langlois radio-canada new
carlisle